and as daily cases of covet 19 steadily
increase it's putting the spotlight on
large events and gatherings
kate houston spoke to some individuals
about their comfort level going to big
events
she joins us live in the newsroom with
how venues in our area are responding
kate
yes christian this conversation ramped
up after multiple people reported
getting coveted after attending
golden knights games t-mobile was at
full capacity with 18 thousand fans
i asked the health district about this
they have not traced any outbreak to a
game
but they encourage those wanting to
attend these events to get vaccinated
now over the next few weeks many large
events will return to las vegas
including two popular concerts at
allegiant stadium and a ufc fight at
t-mobile arena
given the recent rise in cases i asked
visitors if they think
venues should ask for vaccination status
or require masks
be hard to do you know if you ask
somebody you know if you need to be
vaccinated to get in and you just ask
them they're going to say yes so
i don't know mixed feelings i think that
is giving people
free reign to just not wear a mask and
so
my opinion is that it's going to put us
back into lockdown
according to the health district there
is no current discussion about
increasing restrictions on venues or
businesses in clark county
allegion stadium's website states it
aligns with guidance from the cdc
and the state of nevada they do require
those who are unvaccinated to wear a
mask
mgm resorts which operates t-mobile
arena sent me this statement
they are strongly encouraging employees
and the community to get the vaccine
fully vaccinated guests are not required
to wear a mask
the company will also follow guidance
from the cdc and health officials
another big event coming up fourth of
july only a few days away
if you're unvaccinated it is recommended
that you wear a mask